you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess
Tom's tactics trainer and I just got
done working through about 25 or so
puzzles and from them I've selected
three to share with you they're all
endgame puzzles and in each case it's
white to move so feel free to treat this
as a little bit of a pop quiz I'll
simply be presenting each of these three
asking you to pause the video see if you
can work them out and then I'll provide
the solution and any explanation that is
necessary so again if you'd like to go
ahead and pause the video in this first
of three see if you can figure out the
best continuation for white okay with
this one it's very important to
recognize a defensive resource that
block has it may at first glance appear
well I just pushed this pawn and it
can't be caught and that was mine my
first impression and I was a bit taken
aback by blacks reply here which is
Bishop to EE which is really the move
that needs to be calculated because
we're now in an interesting position
where our pawn is being attacked and if
we don't move it it gets captured and if
the pawn takes the bishop Black is just
recapturing it's a drum therefore we
have to promote and the big question at
this point is what exactly to promote
too if you go with the queen or the rook
we have a case of stalemate bishops
pinned notice the g8 squares covered the
King has the other three same story with
the Queen the knight is not working
either
this is the rarest case the rarest
promotion the bishop is the only one
that does the job and now the bishop has
to move for black if he maintains if he
stays on this diagonal
we end up having a matin - to mean -
regardless of where the bishop goes but
this would be the main - Bishop e7 and
then Bishop b5 that's game over and if
the bishop chooses to stay on this dog
and I'll somewhere here we have first
this one quiet move Bishop f7 and then
there's nothing to prevent Bishop e7
mate next and that's going to do it so
really this was the key idea to see the
defensive resource of Bishop EA and know
that the only way to victory is to
actually have this rarest under
promotion to a bishop okay let's try
puzzle number two there we go
once again it's white to move if you'd
like to go ahead pause the video see if
you can find the best continuation for
white okay this one is pretty much a zoo
swing type puzzle this is the mmm pretty
much try to impose that type of position
on black where regardless of what move
they make they have to weaken their
position and they're going to allow
white something the the winning
continuation with this one is just
looking at the forcing move we can play
first f5 and after King h6
we push g5 this has to be captured and
now after King g4 you'll note that there
is only one legal move all the e the e7
pon g5 on h7 pond and King have no legal
moves therefore g6 must be played and
now we can just bypass that pond with f6
now there's only one there's only one
legal move again having
caPSURE we push and we're going to be
cleaning King g7 or f5 we're just we're
pushing through it we'll f5 we would
just move the King but we're basically
pushing through this is the this is the
big trick I don't think this one was
maybe so difficult because there weren't
so many candidate candidate moves here
pretty much have to just see f5 and
really what more would there be from
move to so maybe this one wasn't so
tricky to figure out because there's a
lot of must moves in this one but still
an interesting idea to recognize at
least this moment here this position
where black is kind of stuck still
working with five pieces but four of
them are shut down I have to go with g6
and you push through okay let's have a
look at this one last one which is
certainly in endgame study so feel free
to spend some time on this one it's
quite interesting I scratched my head
for some time with this one and then the
light bulb finally went on so it's white
to move if you'd like to I encourage you
to spend some time with these it's a
good test good exercise for your
calculation like to move see if you can
find the best continuation okay well a
couple of things to note with this one
and that is if we aren't fast enough to
get towards the Kings side this is going
to be a draw maybe that's not the best
way to introduce this problem if black
didn't have these two pawns let's just
say note the black King would be in
stalemate all the squares are covered g7
is covered if white wants to avoid if
white does not want to let's say put
black in stalemate
the bishop has to no longer defend g7
but when that happens the King takes the
pawn and when the King takes the pawn
there's now no stopping King takes g6
unless the White King is there to help
the trick with this one is to somehow
get the King over to g6 over towards the
Kings side to help defend these pawns
how exactly do you do that this is what
needs to be calculated this is the
winning continuation and you have to
really work all of these moves out the
King has to approach the g6 pawn and
there's one key square he has to make
use of and it's a super timely puzzle
first move is King b3 black could go
with either a four or promote right away
let's just say a four we don't take the
pawn just to highlight if we take the
pawn black would promote we take and
stalemate so we need to keep the black
pawns around in the meantime head
towards the Kings side to be a bit more
exact we're heading towards a key square
e 5 why is this square so important
we're gonna find out soon enough
a3 king D 5 there's only one legal
at this point you have to promote Bishop
takes Queen a - and now how do we stop
the bishop from defending g7 we
interfere with King he 5 he's just
masking the bishop for just one key
moment which allows King takes pawn and
now we play King f5 with check and it's
winning isn't that a cool one I really I
really like that one it was it was neat
to get it when you know when the light
bulb finally goes on and you recognize
oh the bishops on a one and then we
could have that little interference type
idea the King takes the fun and then
he's over just in the nick of time to
defend g6 and this is gonna be winning
from here just to I don't know play it
out a little bit eventually the King has
to come out and then we're pushing
through next so an interesting group of
three feel free to leave any feedback to
this video as usual let me know how you
did with each of these three and I hope
you got something out of it
that's all for now take care